all right so the first variation we're
gonna go over is her ethereal variation
and Steve I don't know if you've heard
this don't talk during the intros people
get kind of mad about that i watch the
stream i know i OS you 16-bit if he does
yeah blow him up for sure
so you and I do not even think you're
right all right as you'll never lose
that beauty she looks amazing in this
game all right now for we're gonna go
over her common moves to start off with
Jojo move around a little bit I think
this was movements just really elegant
yes she will get into that we got plenty
of time right so first her common
specials she has this great side she
injects that you're doing on a double
size she has her teleport and of course
you can do her he acts top ward she has
her traditional fall role and if I could
remember there we go and of course she
can see that's them that's common across
all marriages all right what's special
to this specific variation is the fact
that she can teleport and she can
actually disappear for extended period
of time
she's a forward she can go back so what
you can do is do some fun little mix-up
compost where you actually set yourself
behind the layer to do more it'll also
be really good for running away from the
opponent Bootle a keep away game or if
somebody's trying to just kind of zone
you out you just had to hold it down and
extend it and whenever you want to come
back and she has an ax version of that
which hides are even better it's funny
cuz we would play we've played this
variation and her Mac has his disappear
but there are moments of time during the
game where we just both disappear yes
it's pretty it's pretty much and you'll
notice her personality is very prevalent
in this game as well she likes to play
around with the opponents and stuff like
that so I'm really excited to show it
off and for the most part for a theory
old NZ it's all about the setups of you
sighs all right this is gonna be really
interesting to see
people take to this this variation just
starting a combo going behind going the
other direction always moving around
right yeah mobile version which is
definitely the most mobile and properly
one of the best for if someone has good
selling attacks of projectile attacks
hiding from that then I think eventually
people will have setups where they into
combo and then teleport directly behind
them or maybe right in front of them or
they don't teleport at all and that will
be kind of a mix-up I also like to call
it the trollee variation because once
you gotta like me you can just keep
hiding yourself and get them away from
the opponent so with that said sure
let's go to the next area well why'd you
just finish them off for good all right
truly girl's gotta eat
that's right screaming [ __ ] let's uh
let's check out some the other ones okay
absolutely let's do that now after that
we talked about variations a lot and
what we have seen when picked kids real
quick here is that Molina's everything
is so different and I've seen you play
with each variation and each variation I
have to learn how to combat that yeah
you're done milena you betray me too
I prefer the winnings what what uh what
I do really like about Lena - is that
your combos are pretty much universal
except they get a different twist on
them right
so with this version milena the ravenous
she has bite combos where she actually
will fight the jump on their tomato and
you can actually do a button input right
but in addition to that she also has
some command chain graphs as well would
you have practiced before the spirit
yeah and you were doing very well
I was so we'll see how I do here another
percent success rate so so you can do
just the normal one and she'll just roll
back or you can a new post you can
extend it with the spice tab or you can
do it again and do a kick event so
depend upon where you want that
placement on screen that's how you're
gonna extend it or if you want to do the
the maximum damage you're gonna do all
three hits right so if you want to kick
them into the corner you could choose to
do the final ender but if you want to
keep a mid screen or maybe swap
positions you can choose to end it it -
right and so for her other one which is
called the low pounce
she will actually leapfrog over the
player which we suspect a couple people
are gonna love to do this to their
opponent you finished matches with being
with it
yeah I'm sketching over it because it's
so much fun it's fun for me - yeah
but of course you can extend this one as
well so she'll go into that break their
arms right and then she'll roll away or
you can extend it
do I do the wrong fathers all right boy
you knew this was coming
or she will just go ahead and sit on
there it is bouncing off the ground
right and so she gets the the additional
bike combo she also gets the the chain
grabs and this variation as well and
you'll notice that she doesn't have the
mask so you can see her creating very
pretty face so this would you say would
be a more making your favorite movie
Molina oh yeah a little bit yeah exactly
it's gonna be really good for mix ups
you'll be able to mix up over for
through the overhead attack or the low
grabs when you say just for those who
don't play a lot of fighting games when
you say something like mix up mix up
meaning you have to make the opponent
guess between which attack you're going
to be maybe it's an attack that they
have to block standing or an attack that
they have to block ducking so you're
basically going to put them in a
position where they have to guess what
you want to do gotcha
all right so for her last variation my
personal favorite is the piercing I've
seen this one a few times for you this
is the one I usually good I'm excited
you're able to talk about Molina things
like my dad looks a we get to fight with
uh the breakdown hopefully all the
Molina players out there will be super
happy and I'll let it get to see her
house yeah they couldn't be you know
that the older gods the war straight and
now with her side variation or piercing
variation
we'll do the exercise but she also has
this most split side that she can do too
so you can just kind of don't turn it
out right just be like and you have to
block low yes good them yeah and of
course you can yes it where she'll do an
additional side tag too and also what's
special to this is she has Sai combos as
well and just like the biting one you
can extend this attack so she does
additional and then she has this one
which is kind of like a classic mk2
fatality right and one more as well and
like we say before you can extend a lot
of or you can combo Rubick for you
before you finish off cuddle helped Alex
Molina get some meter here oh so we can
do her x-ray and an x-ray and also I
think she has a really cool room oh yeah
while you're totally pumped I've never
seen such a great color
so her x-ray
Oh buddy take a bite out of crime go and
throw them in awesome yes dear soon
we'll be kind of the middle ground where
she has improved projectile with a low
projectile and then those side combos
are gonna be really good your big
damaging combos and really stylish too
absolutely
so we'll get more into Molina later when
we do some fights and sure you're gonna
see some Molina very shortly